you see any trends for me to use with my  students to connect with parents my most  practical advice to a sixth grade  teacher is to try to build a self-esteem  to materialise that would be that's the  thing I spent my entire life thinking  about which is the only tool against all  the pressures that our kids face selphie  weapon so I only have one teacher ever  that I saw  now we're winding my brain and realized  what she was doing that went first in my  person in her class and accelerated and  celebrated their unique individual specs  whether it's sports school personality  humor kindness  whatever it was she built self-esteem  and that's why